so we have a couple of functions here
this is the graph of y is equal to f of
x this is the graph of y is equal to g
of x and we already know something or we
know we know ways to represent the area
under the curve y equals f of x between
these two points x is equal to a and x
equal to b so this area right over here
this area right over here between the
curve and the x axis
between x equals a and x equals b we
know we can write that as the definite
integral from a to b
of f of x
dx and we could do the same thing over
here we could call
we could call this area let me pick a
color that i have not used well this is
a slightly different green
i could call this area right over here
the area under the curve y is equal to g
of x
and above the positive x-axis between x
equals a and x equals b we could call
that the definite integral from a to b
of g of x
dx
now given these two things let's
actually think about the area under the
curve of the function created by the sum
of these two functions so what do i mean
by that so let me
this is actually a fun thing to do let
me start again that's that's exactly
what we have over here this is the graph
of y is equal to f of x but what i want
to do is i want to approximate the graph
of
y is equal to so my goal is to graph
y
is equal to f of x
f of x
plus g of x
plus
g of x
plus g of x
so for any given x it's going to be f of
x so that's the f of x and i'm going to
add the g of x to it so what would that
look like so that's going to look like
let's see at when x is 0 g of x looks
like it's about that length right there
i'm obviously approximating it so i'm
going to have to add that length right
over here so i'd probably be right
around there at x equals a it's a little
bit more
and so but now my f of x curve has gone
more it has has increased but if i take
that same distance above it if i add the
g of x there it gets me right about
there once again i'm just eyeballing it
trying to get an approximation give you
an intuition actually for what f of x
plus g of x is i'm just trying to add g
of x for a given x
now let's see if i'm a little bit let's
say that i'm between a and b g of x is
about that distance
right over there
so
if i wanted to put that same distance
right over here
it gets me right about
there
and then when x is equal to b g of x is
about that big so i have to add that
length which is about
which looks something
something like that that actually looks
like a little bit too much maybe
something
like that
so if i were to add the two
if i were to add the two i get a curve
that looks something like this
that looks something like this and maybe
just keeps on going higher and higher so
this is the curve or it's a pretty good
approximation of the curve of f of x
plus g of x
now an interesting question is
is what would be
well we know how we can represent this
area so the area under the curve f of x
plus g of x above the positive x-axis
between the between x equals a and x
equals b we know we can represent that
as
let me see i have not used
pink yet
so
this area right over here
we know that that could be represented
as the definite integral from a to b
of f of x
of f of x plus g of x
plus g of x
dx
now the question is how does this thing
relate to these or how does this area
relate to these areas right over here
well the important thing to realize is
this area that we have in yellow
that's going to be this area
right over here
that one's pretty clear that one's
pretty clear but how does this area in
green
relate to this area there
and to think about that we just have to
think about what what does an integra
what does an integral mean remember what
does it represent we've already thought
about these like these really small
rectangles
we're taking the sum of an infinitely
num or the limit as we get an infinite
number of these infinitely thin
rectangles but when we're thinking about
riemann sums we're thinking about okay
we have some change in x and then you
multiply it times essentially the height
which is going to be the value of the
function at that point
well over here
you could have the same change in x you
could have the exact same change in x
and what is the height right over here
well that's going to be this exact
height right over here we saw that when
we constructed it this is going to be
the g of x at that value
so even though the rectangles look like
they're kind of shifted around a little
bit and they're actually all shifted up
by the f of x the heights of these
rectangles that i'm drawing right over
here
are exactly the same thing as the
heights of the rectangles that i'm
drawing over here they once again they
are all just shifted up and down by this
by this f of x function but these are
the exact same rectangles or they have
the exact same heights and the limit as
you get more and more of these by making
them thinner and thinner is going to be
the same as the limit you get more and
more of these as you get thinner and
thinner and so this area right over here
and i'm obviously not doing a rigorous
proof i'm giving you the intuition for
it is the exact same thing as this area
right over here
so the area under this curve the the
definite integral uh from a to b of f x
plus g of x dx is just going to be the
sum of these two is just going to be the
sum of these two definite integrals
and you might say oh this is obvious
well you know when or maybe it's not so
obvious but when is this actually useful
well as you later actually learn to
evaluate these integrals you'll see that
one of the most powerful ideas is being
able to decompose them in this way to
say okay if i'm taking
if i'm taking the definite integral from
0 to 1 of x squared plus sine of x
which you may or may not have learned to
do so far you can at least start to
break this down you can say okay well
this is going to be the same thing as
the integral from 0 to 1 of x squared dx
plus the integral from 0 to 1
of sine of x
dx and you see this is one of the most
powerful principles of definite
integrals to make them to when you start
to try to compute them or even sometimes
conceptualize what they are representing